ou aussi parlé de nos efforts pour
soutenir l'ukraine passe à l'agression
russe est évidemment commençons par la
situation ici au canada
les goûts ont perturbé la vie de trop de
canadiens ici dans notre capitale
nationale des familles de commerçants
connus l'obstruction illégal de leur
quartier une occupation de nauru
l'harcèlement des gens des empreintes à
la loi ce n'est pas une manifestation
pacifique aux frontières ailleurs comme
ici les blocages font du mal à notre
économie et mettre en péril la sécurité
publique les chaînes d'approvisionnement
critique ont été perturbés ceci fait du
mal du tort aux travailleurs et aux
travailleuses qui ont besoin de ces
emplois pour m
l'épicerie sur la table hier le point
bas serait rouvert entre detroit et
windsor
mon équipe et moi avons travaillé avec
ave le wonder et la province de
l'ontario jour et nuit et j'aimerais
remercier les policiers sur le terrain y
est qu la grc qui ont joué un rôle
critique
qu'ils vont mettre la responsabilité de
s'assurer que le pont demeure ouvert
avec chaque blocage illégal
les forces de l'ordre locales qui agit
afin de maintenir la paix dans leur
juridiction
malgré leur mère c'est fort il est
maintenant clair qu'il n'ya les défis
énormes aux forces de l'ordre et à leur
capacité de mettre en exécution nous
mettre en application la loi vendredi
l'ontario a évoqué l'état d'urgence
provincial afin de régir au blocage
c'était la chose responsable est
nécessaire à faire
aujourd'hui
en s'inspirant des efforts le
gouvernement fédéral est prêt à
recourir à plus d' outils à sa
disposition pour maîtriser la situation
après avoir discuté au sein du caucus et
du conseil des ministres après des
consultations avec mes homologues de
partout au canada
après m'être entretenu avec elle est
dans la position le gouvernement fédéral
est en train d'évoquer la loi des
mesures d'urgence
pour
rajouter aux capacités provinciales et
territoriales pour mettre fin au blocage
j'aimerais être bien compris la portée
de ces mesures sera limitée d'un sont
géographiquement cible y est aussi de
nature raisonnable et proportionnelle
face aux menaces en face la loi seraient
utilisés pour renforcer soutenir les
forces de l'ordre à tous les niveaux
partout au canada et les questions de
protéger les canadiens et leurs emplois
et de rétablir la confiance en nos
institutions
mais aussi comment les mesures annoncées
aujourd'hui vont aider à maîtriser la
situation
la police aura plus de 6 à sa
disposition pour établir l'ordre là où
des rassemblements publics peuvent
représenter les activités illégales
dangereuses telles que les blocages et
les occupations comment ottawa et à
windsor comme ailleurs c'est inclus le
renforcement de leur capacité à imposer
des amendes ou une peine d'incarcération
le gouvernement va désigner
des endroits et des infrastructures qui
sont critiqués notre économie et à
l'emploi déjà et inclut des passages
frontaliers et les aéroports
nous le pouvons et nous n'allons pas
permettre à des activités illégales et
dangereux de continuer voire le père du
risque
cette loi va permettre aussi au
gouvernement de s'assurer que les
services essentiels soient offerts par
exemple pour que l'on puisse remorquer
des véhicules qu'ils bloquent les
chemins publics de plus les institutions
financières seront autorisées ou
demander à offrir des services
essentiels pour aider à rétablir la
situation et accule par le règlement et
l'interdiction d'utilisation de
propriété pour financer des blocages si
l'ego finalement les gers et pourra
faire appliquer des règlements
municipaux
là où ce sera nécessaire
voilà ce que la loi prévoit
donc j'aimerais être tout aussi clair
sur ce que cela ne veut pas dire si nous
ne nous servons pas de cette loi pour
faire appel aux militaires nous ne
suspendrons aucune bonne les droits
fondamentaux et nous le nôtre passons
pas du tout la charte des droits et
libertés nous ne limitons pas la liberté
parole ne les mettons pas le droit
d'assemblée publique et pacifique nous
n'empêchons pas les gens d'exercer leur
droit à manifester de façon légale
ce nous renforçons les principes les
valeurs et les institutions
définissent nos libertés les discussions
avec le conseil des ministres et le
caucus après avoir consulté les premiers
ministres de toutes les provinces et
tous les territoires et après avoir
parlé avec les chefs de l'opposition
le gouvernement fédéral évoque la loi
sur les mesures d'urgence pour compléter
les pouvoirs provinciaux et territoriaux
visant à gérer d'occupation et les
barrages illégaux
je veux être très clair ces mesures vont
être limitées dans le temps et ciblées g
elles vont être raisonnable et
proportionnel aux menaces à la sécurité
du canada
la loi sur les mesures d'urgence pour
renforcer et soutenir le travail des
policiers
on ne se sert pas de la loi des mesures
d'urgence pour des foyers l'armée on ne
suspend pas les droits fondamentaux
prévu dans la charte des droits et
libertés on ne limite pas la liberté
d'expression ni le droit de manifester
pacifiquement
ce qu'on veut c'est d'assurer la
sécurité des canadiens protéger les
emplois des travailleurs et rétablir la
confiance dans nos institutions
emergencies à 19h centaines d'espagnols
existe
le fait d'évoquer la loi n'est jamais la
première de la saison la deuxième non il
faut s'en servir avec parcimonie et
vraiment interne y recourent
aujourd'hui la situation qui prévaut
nécessaire d'autres mesures si
qui ne sont pas à la disposition des
forces de l'ordre selon les lois
actuelles et donc en lien avec les
circonstances que l'on connaît
c'est faire preuve de leadership
responsable que de
passer à l'invoquer sans cette loi ces
mesures seront en conformité avec la
charte des droits et libertés en fait la
loi sur les mesures d'urgence a été créé
à la fin des années 80
pour justement
faire appliquer la loi des chiens la
loupe la charte des droits et des
libertés donc
il faut dire que ces blocs à chantilly
et si vous participez encore il est
temps de rentrer la maison
sur une voie parallèle à cette loi
j'aimerais rassurer mes chances
l' agence des services frontaliers et
déjà un trait de bloquer l'entrée au
canada à des gens qui veulent participer
au blocage bien sûr pendant que nous
maîtrisons la situation nous allons
continuer de nous préoccuper des
canadiens j'aimerais m'adresser aux
commerces affectés si vous avez les
pertes de revenus vous avez de soutien
grâce à nos programmes nous savons que
le centre-ville d'ottawa surtout les
boutiquiers ont été durement frappées
par ces activités illégales les choses à
venir nous allons lancer des mesures de
soutien pour ces commerçants
je sais que chacun et chacune
est vraiment fatigué de parler mais nous
entendons vos frustrations
que ce soit avec la coved où les mesures
temporaires pour vous protéger vous et
vos proches je sais que les gens vivent
de la frustration intense où je
l'entends vous avez le droit d'exprimer
cette frustration et même votre colère
et bienvenue quand il est question des
politiques doivent mental nous allons
toujours défendre votre droit de
protester dans ce pays démocratique et
libre mais le fait de bloquer des rues
des chemins publics des infrastructures
critiques et le fait de priver
de leur liberté alors là on change la
donne
il faut que ça cesse
et fatigué de la pandémie il ya d'autres
façons de vous exprimer que de
participer à des activités illégales et
dangereuses
comme le ministre du clos l'a dit la
semaine passée les mesures de santé
publique sont constamment réévaluée on
va continuer de les modifier en fonction
de la science on va justement avoir
quelques annonces à faire à ce sujet
dans les prochains jours
aujourd'hui j'aimerais également abordé
brièvement le soutien que l'on veut
exprimer à l'égard de l'ukraine samedi
je me sens un entretien avec le
président alain ski pour affirmer à
nouveau une autre soutien indéfectible
faut faire tout ce que nous pouvons pour
soutenir l'ukraine
avec le président du conseil européen
charles michel avec le chancelier choc
de l'allemagne est avec le président du
rdda de la pologne
de la réaction générale du g7 pour
renforcer la résilience économique de
l'ukraine nous annonçons aujourd'hui que
nous allons offrir un prêt de jusqu'à
500 millions de dollars
et nous remercions madame et cuisine de
son leadership dans ce dossier et nous
soulignons que c'est en plus
120 millions que nous avons prêté
l'ukraine au mois de janvier
ce soutien financier
le canada a déjà franchi certains
d'étape pour aider l'ukraine à défendre
rien qu avec le prolongement de la
mission
ému ni unifiés
sérieux de la situation et suite à des
dialogues avec nos homologues ukrainiens
j'ai approuvé
sept millions de dollars d'équipements
létale et de munitions
ceci est en réaction une demande
explicite de l'ukraine et essai en plus
de l'équipement non létale que nous
avons déjà fourni le cresson les
tensions du canada et les autres
partenaires c'est de dissuader d'autres
agresseurs russe sérieux de la situation
et après avoir soigneusement examiné la
question j'ai approuvé la demande de
l'ukraine de le renvoyer l'armement et
des munitions
le canada se joint donc aux états unis
au royaume uni à la bulgarie la
république tchèque l'estonie la lettonie
la lituanie aux pays bas et à la pologne
dans l'envoi d'armement le but de ce
soutien de la part du canada et de nos
autres partenaires et de dissuader la
russie poursuivre son agression contre
l'ukraine
sont certainement pas l'affrontement là
car l'uci mais aussi de façon c'est un
sifi rapidement
et nous voulons faire preuve de
détermination
il est important pour les canadiens le
monde entier veut savoir que le canada
va continuer de soutenir l'ukraine
tout comme son indépendance son
intégrité territoriale sa souveraineté y
est eu son droit à défendre son
territoire
à la vice première ministre
[Musique]
merci monsieur le premier ministre
bonjour tout le monde à travers le monde
les démocraties libérales sont
confrontés à des menaces sérieuses et
répété nous avons peut-être penser et
peut-être même espérer que le canada
serait et parier
depuis deux semaines et demie nous avons
réalisé que ce n'est pas le cas ce siège
et ses barrages cause des dommages
importante un autre économie un autre
aux institutions démocratiques et à la
réputation du canada dont le monde
la confiance et internationales envers
le canada comme endroit propice aux
investissements et pour faire des
affaires et et prenait 10 et rigoberto
ces barrages illégaux ou de tort à notre
économie
sans parler de notre réputation comme
partenaire commercial fiable
le blocage du pont ambassador affecté
environ
390 millions de dollars en commerce à
chaque jour
ce pont représente 30% de tout le
commerce route si entre le canada et
notre voisin du sud en fait un
partenaire à part ça le plus important
en alberta environ 48 millions de
dollars commerciaux quotidiens est
affecté par ray les barrages a amusé ce
nouvel touba environ 73 millions $ de
commercial quotidien
affecté par les barrages ces cours sont
réels tangibles et concrets
met en péril les commerces petits et
grands et il menace le gagne pain de
canaliser de canadiennes
tout cela pendant que nous travaillons
d'arrache-pied pour nous rétablir après
les dommages économiques causés par la
pandémie
pour protéger la pression privilégié du
canada avec les états unis lors des
négociations de l'alena et nous nous
sommes chez nous débout face aux tarifs
232 qui était et légaux et injustifiée
nous ne laisserons pas cette victoire
durement gagnés être garni le monde nous
regarde
nos emplois notre prospérité et nous
gagne pagne sont en jeu
c'est pourquoi notre gouvernement agit
nous sommes résolus et déterminé ces
barrages et légaux doivent être lavés et
ils le seront
qu'une image de l'évocation de cette loi
soit mesures d'urgence nous annonçons ce
qui suit comme gestes concrets et
immédiats première manche nous
élargissons la portée de la loi contre
le blanchiment d'argent et le
financement du terrorisme afin que les
plates formes de financements sociaux
puissent être compris ces changements
une urgence couvrir toutes les formes de
transactions conclues les avoirs
numériques tels que les crypto monnaie
les
blocages
illégaux ont souligné que le
sous-financement et quelques uns des
prestataires de se laisser danser ils ne
sont pas vraiment couverts par la loi
sur le financement du terrorisme et les
recettes une criminalité nos banques et
les institutions financières doivent
déjà signalé aux autorités fédérales
ce qui se passe ça s'appelle une traque
à partir d'aujourd'hui toutes les
plateformes le sous-financement et les
prestataires de services financiers
doivent s'enregistrer avec finn trac et
ils devront signaler les transactions
importantes ou douteuse affine traque
ceci va aider à atténuer le risque que
ces plateformes puisse recevoir des
fonds et les sites cela va augmenter la
qualité la côte est il des
renseignements reçus par finn trac et
cela rendra plus d'informations
disponibles afin de soutenir les
enquêtes des autorités
quand il est question des blocages
illégaux nous apportons ces changements
car nous savons que ces plateformes
sont exploités pour soutenir des
activités illégales et des blocages et
les barrages illégal illégaux pardon et
cela faisait du tort à l'économie
canadienne nous allons également
proposer un projet de loi pour que ses
autorités puissent être pérennisé
schaffen chaque 2 emma nous émettons en
donnant ce à effet immédiat en vertu de
la loi sur les mesures d'urgence
autorisant les institutions financières
canadiennes de
était d'offrir des services financiers
de façon temporaire là où il ya un doute
qu'un conte est utilisé pour
soutenir les occupations et les barrages
illégaux ceux ci courent à la fois des
comptes personnels et commerciaux
c'est-à-dire industriel 3m à nos
demandes aux institutions financières
canadiennes je passe en revue la
relation avec toute personne impliquée
dans les bloquages illégaux et de
signaler à la grc ou à d'autres agences
de renseignement
aujourd'hui les bords ou des
prestataires de services financiers
pourront immédiatement gelé il suspendre
compte sans mandat de tribunal ce
faisant ils vont être protégés contre
une responsabilité civile pour des
gestes posés en toute bonne foi des
institutions fédérales auront donc une
authority élargie afin de partager des
renseignements pertinents avec des
banques et d'autres prestataires de
services financiers afin de s'assurer
que nous puisons tous travailler main
dans la main pour mettre fin au
financement de ces gestes illégaux que
représentent les barrages il est
question de suivre la trace financière
il est question de stopper le
financement de ces blocages et légaux
aujourd'hui nous annonçons donc que si
votre camion
est utilisé dans ces barrages votre
compte commercial sera julie
l'assurance qui couvre votre véhicule
sera suspendu
envoyez donc vous serez mes remarques à
la maison l'économie canadienne a besoin
de ces remorques sur les routes et non
entre elles de nous faire souffrir de
nous appauvrir collectivement suivre
l'argent il s'agit de mettre fin au
financement de ces blocages élégant
considérez vous avertis c'est votre cas
mais en est utilisé dans ces blocages
vos comptes d'entreprises seront gelés
l'assurance de votre véhicule sera
suspendu
envoyez vos super remorque chez eux
l'économie canadienne a besoin qu'ils
fassent un travail légitime et pas
qu'ils nous ont tous illégalement plus
pauvres nous annonçant ces mesures après
mûre réflexion
je me suis entretenu directement avec
les dirigeants des banques canadiennes
je tiens à les remercier de faire le
nécessaire pour assurer le respect des
lois et de la démocratie canadienne et
pour protéger notre économie
team canada atlantique équipe canada a
été vraiment solidaire depuis deux ans
nous nous sommes fait confiance nous
avons été solidaires de façon
remarquable
aujourd'hui on fait face à une menace à
notre démocratie notre économie et à la
paix l'ordre et au gouvernement chez
nous ici au canada pts c'est
inacceptable
c'est intolérable et nous allons y
mettre fin je vous remercie
mais
nous sommes régis par la règle de droit
en déclarant urgence public en vertu de
la loi nous suivons la loi et nous
agissons dans le cadre de la loi il est
déconcentré clèves prévues par cette loi
afin que nous puissions décréter
l'urgence notre gouvernement estime que
ces conditions sont réunies effet exige
du canada que le gouvernement
depuis 1988 et remplacer la loi sur les
mesures de guerre elle est différente de
cette dernière de deux façons très
importante premièrement la loi sur les
mesures d'urgence contient plusieurs
balises et sauvegarde dont une examen
parlementaire
deuxièmement les mesures prises en vertu
de la loi doivent respecter la charte
canadienne des droits et libertés
et moi je suis à que l'on est bien loin
de ceux évoqués dans 6 cas graves qui
correspondait
urgence nationale
et c'est quoi une urgence trois
conditions doivent être réunies
premièrement il nous faut nous retrouver
où il ya danger pour la vie la santé ou
la sécurité des canadiens et dépasse la
capacité ou l'autorité d'une province
une menace grave
pour le gouvernement du canada
quand il est question de protéger
l'intégrité territoriale ou la peste
canada
la capacité provincial de composés de la
situation doit être vue comme
insuffisante ou
connaître des lacunes inscrits
troisièmement il faut conclure que la
situation ne peut pas être juré en vertu
2 inclut loi provinciale ou territoriale
déclaré la loi sur les mesures d'urgence
permet au gouvernement fédéral d'adopter
les décrets ou les règlements
nécessaires pour intervenir
notre gouvernement respecte les droits
et libertés des canadiens quelques
protégé par la charte c'est notre
intention d'utiliser uniquement les
pouvoirs nécessaires raisonnable et
mesurée pour résoudre la crise de façon
rapide et sécuritaire
compter les limites des freins et
contrepoids
vertu de la loi un peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui à quelques reprises depuis
une semaine le premier ministre et les
membres du conseil des ministres ont
consulté les premiers ministres et les
homologues de l'horaire entraînement et
a déclaré l'urgence nationale nous
allons déposer la déclaration parlement
tel qu'exigé du 6ème jour dans les jours
à venir qui était parlementaires seront
constituées afin d'assurer une
surveillance tout pendant que l'état
d'urgence dans vigueur
la déclaration ne dure que 30 jours aff
à moins qu'elle soit renouvelée et nous
espérons certainement révoqué l'état
d'urgence bien avant cela le programme a
également la possibilité aux rivaux qui
la déclaration d'urgence nationale telle
que prévue par la loi
une fois que les gens s'étaient déclarés
la loi permet aux formats fédéral
d'apporter des changements c'est à dire
de faire adopter des règlements des
décrets le ministre en a parlé dans ses
remarques
si lourd spécifique qui selon nous sont
nécessaires pour maîtriser la situation
qui prévaut premièrement
un bruit de mission de l'assemblée
qui va au delà des manifestations
passées fait qu'est ce que nous voyons à
3 par exemple est ce qu'on a vu
ce pont ambassador ce ne sont pas des
manifestations légales notamment le fait
de désigner des endroits où les blocages
doivent être interdits que ceux ci
pourraient inclure des frontières les
abords des frontières et d'autres
infrastructures critiques ou encore
ottawa
ou gens libres d'offrir des services
est influencé la situation je sens son
remorqueuse autorisés ou ont des
positions financières d'offrir des
services essentiels afin d'alléger
l'impact des blocages et inclut comme
d'appeler l'asie le fais de empêcher
l'utilisation de la propriété pour
soutenir les blocages
qui permettent à le gers et de faire
appliquer les règlements municipaux et
des infractions provinciales là où c'est
nécessaire et finalement l'imposition
d'amendés ou de peines d'incarcération
quand on a un frère tout ordre d'un
tribunal où toute injonction accordé
qui permettront de concrétiser les
mesures seront élaborés super et déposé
devant le parlement dans les deux jours
de séance suivant la date de leur prise
comme la loi comme exige la loi le
parlement a le pouvoir de révoquer un
décret ce qui assure que toutes les
mesures prises le seront de manière
responsable et mesurée et dans le
respect des balises établies
au final je bats souligner un point
mais je ces mesures sont temporaires
nous avons l'intention d imposer
cependant cela s'avère nécessaire pour
rétablir l'autre au canada je vous
remercie
de questions en commençant avec les
journalistes dans la salle
question monsieur trudeau
premier ministre thériault qu'en dit
qu'ils n'avaient pas du fédéral en train
d'exercer ses pouvoirs en vertu de la
loi sur les mesures d'urgence dans leur
territoire promet salle territoriales
comment vous réagissez à cela s'il vous
plaît réponse et je les remercie
car on allait changer là dessus ce matin
il est très important que nous
interrogions sur ce qui se passe chacun
l'a bien
vu des défis au canada li est ce que
nous avons vu comme situation aux
passages frontaliers çà et là où dans la
capitale nationale mais permettez moi de
répondre ce que j'ai déjà dit
les mesures annoncées aujourd'hui
vraiment ciblé sur le plan géographique
et les cibles et donc là on en a besoin
ce ne sont pas des pouvoirs généralisé
sur tout le territoire canadien non ce
sont des outils sebli
on s'en servira là où on a besoin afin
que la police juridictionnelle qui fait
face à l'ock passons à des blocages
ce suisse avoir à leur disposition des
outils nécessaires et
puisse faire appel à la grc pour assurer
la protection des canadiens pour
rétablir la confiance dans la règle de
droit et dans nos institutions
nationales et afin de s'assurer que
notre économie puisse continuer de
fleurir quand il est question de se
rétablir de ces pandémies et de tous les
effets et les raids pour quelque chose
économique depuis deux ans
question quelqu'un dit que c'est comme
être de jeter de l'huile sur le feu
qu'en pensez vous
pensez vous que vous êtes en train
d'aggraver la situation
réponse écoutez moi je m'intéresse aux
canadiens et aux canadiennes qui ont
vécu vraiment
montagnes russes depuis deux ans on a
perdu des êtres chers on a vu des
commerces péricliter des emplois
disparaître on veut juste tourner la
page
nous sommes tous vraiment au bout du
rouleau c'est très normal la pandémie il
nous a vraiment grévy
mais quand il est question de regarder
les mesures qu'ont adoptée pour nous
protéger pour que nous puissions nous
permet de tourner la page et d'être
amère pour sauver notre pays les gens
qui ont dû opérer cette transition d'une
manifestation et d'un désaccord public
contre ces mesures
jusqu'à limiter à bloquer la liberté de
leurs concitoyens d'or concitoyennes de
mettre en péril l'emploi de leurs
voisins de mettre en péril la sécurité
publique
affaiblir notre économie non seulement
maintenant mais
réputation que le canada s'est acquise
partout dans le monde ces blocages
illégaux font du tort au canadien il
faut que ça cesse à chaque étape nous
avons été présents pour soutenir les
forces policières locales nous avons été
présents et des outils des ressources
les effectifs pour aider les forces de
l'ordre et rétablir l'ordre
il est clair que d'autres outils
s'avérait nécessaire et c'est pourquoi
nous allons de l'avant avec ces mesures
limitées d'un temps cibler
géographiquement
vraiment resterait selon le cadre de la
loi
afin que nous puissions
vraiment tourné la page sur ces blocages
et reprendre le travail difficile de
relancer notre économie après cette
pandémie
comme on disait le sait ce qui est
certains critères qui vont devant être
rencontrés tout ça mais des premiers
menacent de certaines provinces ont déjà
10 contre 6 des critères étaient
nécessaires selon vous est ce que vous
seriez prêt à aller de l'avant dans des
provinces qui ne veulent pas avoir la
loi appliquée les conversations que nous
sommes en train d'avoir avec tous nos
partenaires à travers le pays et avec il
le police de juridiction qui sont en
train de gérer différentes situations à
travers le pays vont continuer c'est
cette loi sur les mesures d'urgence est
là pour donner des outils additionnels
aux forces policières en place pour
pouvoir régler les situations qui
pourraient surgir
s'est pas automatiquement une
intervention de la police fédérale ou un
un engagement direct du fédéral
on est là pour donner plus d'outils y
compris les autorités additionnel ou
policier nécessaire aux à la police deux
juridictions camps sont nécessaires donc
c'est très possible et on l'espère même
que les outils qu'on a mis de l'avant
aujourd'hui à la disposition de forces
policières à travers le pays
ne seront pas énormément utilisé
certainement port pendant longtemps ce
serait l'idéal que ces premiers
ministres qui disent qu'ils ont tout en
main continue de garder tout en main
mais un niveau national on est rendus
dans les critères
où il fallait agir pour donner plus
d'outils à nos services de l'ordre pour
pouvoir assurer le bien-être de tous les
canadiens d'un bout du pays à l'autre
vous n'êtes que maintenant c'est
nécessaire à temps on entend la
troisième semaine de manifestations
pourquoi pas avoir mis en place les
outils l'oeil deux semaines est ce que
tu sais pas vous manquer à votre devoir
de chemins multiressources cela en place
je comprends qu'il y ait des gens qui
disent on agit trop rapidement il y en a
d'autres qui disent oh non on aurait dû
agir il ya dix semaines
la réalité c'est que la loi sur les
mesures d'urgence n'est pas quelque
chose à prendre à la légère et c'est pas
le premier outil
comprend même le deuxième ou le
troisième
on est était là pour donner plus de
ressources tels débuts à la police
locale ici à ottawa et ailleurs nous
avions été là pour les accompagner dans
le travail qu'ils ont fait
et dans les derniers jours
les rencontres que j'ai eues avec les
ministres avec nos partenaires avec les
hauts fonctionnaires
était clair qu'il ya un besoin d'outils
additionnel ici ces outils la limite est
raisonnable et responsable
qu'on est en train de mettre de l'avant
avec la loi sur les mesures d'urgence
prochaine question
question
le droit de faire mais qui des lois
provinciales et municipales est ce à
dire que l'actrice d'ottawa a des effets
de cela et comme les effectifs d'agir si
vont-ils arriver en renfort la police
d'ottawa quelqu'un aussi répond
ecoutez-le évoqué son la loi soit une
source d' urgence offre plus de pouvoirs
de police de juridiction
salesforce par locales ne transforme pas
la chercher en police municipale où que
ce soit au canada
tel que nous l'avons fait nous allons
nous assurer que la grc pu soutenir les
polices locales les forces policières
saïda et c'est ce qu'on a fait à ottawa
mais j'aimerais patek céder le micro un
petit monsieur mendocino pour qu'il
puisse nous offrir des renseignements
supplémentaires sur la situation qui
prévaut à ottawa monsieur le ministre
merci merci beaucoup
début
ces blocages et des gaules où nous avons
travaillé en étroite collaboration avec
les forces pour les faire local où ils
sont la force policière de jeux
d'actions tel que c'est le cas ici à
ottawa
trois envois d'effectifs supplémentaires
pour s'assurer que la police d'ottawa
puisse avoir tous les effectifs
nécessaires mais sans aucun doute il ya
eu des défis est prévu sur le terrain
dans les efforts visant à rétablir
l'ordre vous n'avez qu'à regarder la rue
wellington depuis quelques femelles pour
le constater elissalde exagéré l'impact
de ce qu'on a vu la conduite et les
comportements qui
était démontrée par les manifestants et
légaux ce n'est pas uniquement une
question d'accommoder les gens ou les
passants ce n'est pas quelque chose
qu'il faut très bien lisez comme
perturbations avec l'intimidation de
l'harcèlement
et on l'a vu aussi des excroissances
et parfois ce qu'on a vu c'est la rue ou
un thème par exemple
cela semblait en tout point l'anarchie
pur c'est pourquoi avec beaucoup de
délibérations on a décidé d'évoquer la
loi qu'on annonce aujourd'hui qu'ils
contiennent justement des pouvoirs qui
sont très ciblés proportionnelle
illimité matin pour qu'on puisse avoir
une meilleure agilité meilleure
souplesse quant à la grc et les forces
locales cela inclut bien sûr ottawa afin
de rétablir l'ordre public
j'aimerais rajouter d'ailleurs sur la
vue du progrès par exemple à wenzhou
qu'il ne faudrait pas présumer que ce
progrès et lumière c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles ces mesures sont
nécessaires
nous voulons nous assurer que les forces
locales
et les outils concrets par exemple les
remords que l'on était introuvable
en plus les gens de barrières pour
limiter le déplacement des foules pour
s'assurer que le commerce et la
circulation puisse être harmonieuse en
plus quand il est question de la
relation entre la grc et les forces de
l'ordre locales ou les forces auraient
salle la disposition cours et ou bien la
déclaration permettra à la grc d'être
plus facilement envoyer
çà et là
que ce soit en vertu des lois locales
mais c'est pas le professeur ou là où il
ya un danger de entrave la paix de
dommages aux infrastructures
économiques critiques donc quand vous
regardez l'éventail des mesures et c'est
le fruit beaucoup de réflexion notre
vision des choses c'est que c'est
nécessaire et que ces outils vont nous
aider à mieux composer avec ces blocages
et les baux et à tourner sur ces
manifestations illégales question vous
avez parlé de la rue boisnet n avait vu
l'anarchie
pourquoi pensez-vous qu'après trois
semaines lalo la police doit sera en
mesure de le changer du tout au tout
réponse écoutez nous avons travaillé en
étroite collaboration avec la police
d'ottawa non seulement par l'entremise
agir si mais aussi la police provinciale
de l'ontario a fait assuré d'une
coordination des forces policières
les questions de la confiance
la qualité de nos policiers je pense
qu'on pourrait laisser la parole à
monsieur muller merci beaucoup monsieur
trudeau bonjour à tous et à toutes
la police d'ottawa et la police de
juridiction sur le territoire des
municipalités de droite mais il savait
ce policier partout vont se regrouper et
vendredi genre annoncé la formation
d'une structure de commandement intégré
face à cet événement et cela peut
regrouper les ressources de la police
provinciale de la police fédérale pour
qu'ils viennent en aide à la police
d'ottawa ils ont reconnu la nature
spécifique das situation qu'ils
préparent à sawa et le besoin de
ressources mais ce n'est pas uniquement
des ressources fossiles autorités elles
dans mon travail d'élu avec les
municipalités et la province afin de
nous assurer que nous services policiers
à taipei et pas toi y en au canada que
savoir
autorités les ressources nécessaires
afin de faire notre match important qui
leur revient comme j'ai dit hier
la police est une institution fort
important dans une société nous avons
besoin et que la police puisse faire
respecter les lois qu'ils puissent
maintenir la règle de droit et faire
respecter la loi et l'ordre tout comme
la paix et c'est important qu'ils
puissent jouir des ressources
nécessaires ils ont notre soutien et à
mesure que ce soutien grandi à ottawa je
suis confiant qu'ils seront en mesure de
rétablir la loi et l'ordre dans la
capitale nationale
nous soulignons que nous faisons aucune
appel aux militaires mais que tous tes
absences en traquant sur la table
qu'est-ce que cela prendrait quel serait
le seuil de bascule pour faire appel aux
militaires
réponse
écoutez je n'accepte pas votre
invitation à la conjecture sur un point
de bascule no mercy je veux qu'il
écrasait reprennent leurs quartiers
commerçants pu se revoir l'afflux des
gens qui déambulent pacifiquement sur
une rue du centre-ville la réalité c'est
que les mesures annoncées aujourd'hui
sont le fruit de réflexions mur offre
des outils aux forces de l'ordre afin
que celle ci puisse être
plus ferme et sapent le preuve de plus
de clarté quand il est question de
mettre fin à ces blocages à ces barrages
qui sèment l'anarchie dans nos villes et
nos rues nous continuons de suivre la
situation et de prendre des décisions
nécessaires pour protéger nos
concitoyens 6 à cette loi que l'on
évoque
rapports avec
les forces armées canadiennes ça n'a
aucun rapport mais qu'elles sont ce week
end se glaire exprimé qu'il était un peu
confondu par le manque des forces de
l'ordre ne vous trou ne trouvez vous pas
que la police d'ottawa n'a pas fait
beaucoup pour faire appliquer la loi
c'est un peut confondre répondu il ya
énormément de frustration chez les
citadins d'ottawa
puisque la situation perdure et perdu
cette frustration ressentie par les
citadines les sites à nay est partagée
par d'autres canadiens et d'ailleurs des
sites web monde entier c'est important
que la police locale de concert avec
d'autres paliers des forces policières
pu se mettre fin à ces manifestations
illégales
les mesures annoncées aujourd'hui cible
est limitée
offriront d'autres outils afin que la
coordination entre la grc la police
promet salle d'interview et la police
d'ottawa
vraiment mieux composer avec la
situation et redonner la ville à ces
citadins quels sont
le maire jim watson il ottawa a conclu
une entente avec les dirigeants de la
manifestation pour que des camions
soient déplacés qu'en pensez-vous de
cette entente conclue réponse je sais
que la ville d'ottawa ses policiers et
ses élus
certains voulu mettre fin à ces
barrages cela perdure est vraiment au
delà de ce qui est raisonnable ses
débuts de manifestations
normal contre les politiques c'est
maintenant une occupation illégale le
temps est venu pour les gens de rentrer
à la maison les mesures annoncées
aujourd'hui sont des outils additionnels
enfin offerte
aux forces de l'ordre pour qu'on puisse
finalement mettre fin à ces barrages
question
les règles sur
le mouvement les fonds en banque et les
manifestants c'est une chose mais là une
entente pour que d'autres camions
puissent rester devant le parlement
qu'en pensez vous réponse écoutez on se
concerte pour que
tous avoir bon espoir que les gens que
la ville puisse reprendre la vie normale
et le fait d'offrir aux banques la
possibilité de bloquer l'usagé des fonds
pour des activités légales ça va de soi
c'est vraiment l'objectif visé c'est de
diminuer l'impact et l'ampleur des
blocages qui sont
s'il vous plaît appuyé sur étoile est
maintenant proposé une question de faire
quoi que moby femme la première question
va être de raymond filion tva pliskova
raid à vous la parole en
vigueur des pouvoirs spéciaux de la loi
sur les mesures d'urgence pour les
policiers j'annonce aujourd'hui
l'impact de cette déclaration est
immédiate nous allons formuler des des
politiques des propositions spécifiques
dans les heures à venir dans les jours à
venir qui vont avoir ces impacts
spécifiques mais je vais me tourner vers
le ministre de la justice qui peut en
parler plus longuement
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur fillion
on va déposer des ordres en conseil en
suivant la loi un fois que les les
autres sondés sont annoncés iran cela en
vigueur et ce sera au parlement de
regarder après de faire le devoir mais
les autres rentrent en vigueur a tout de
suite et c'est
merci j'ai plutôt plusieurs vous ont
reproché votre ton assure manifestants
ces dernières semaines sont accusés
d'avoir jeté d'huile sur leflux en
parlant d'une minorité qui rouspètent
est ce que vous sentez un degré de
responsabilité pour l'ampleur que ces
manifestations ont pris ce qu'on a vu
est ce qu'on voit maintenant à travers
le canada c'est que bien sûr les gens
sont fatigués frustré années de la
pandémie danny des mesures de santé
publique veulent que ce soit fini tout
le monde est d'accord là dessus mais ce
qu'on a vu aussi
c'est que les canadiens à travers le
pays ont été lents les uns pour les
autres ont-ils été là pour s'entraider
poursuivre les mesures de fonction de
santé publique pour se faire vacciner un
plus haut taux que la plupart de nos
pays pairs à travers le monde
on a démontré en tant que pays que les
gens continuent d'être là les uns pour
les autres et maintenant
les gens qui voient leur vie
déboussolés par ces barricades ici à
ottawa de voir les gens souffrir parce
que il ya des blocages aux frontières
qui empêche le faire leur job
limite les chaînes d'approvisionnement
ces gens là sont fâchés et année encore
plus ils veulent qu'on agisse pour
remettre de l'ordre dans notre pays pour
démontrer qu'on est un pays
règles de droit ou oui on encourage et
manifestation paisible on encourage
légende exprimé haut et fort leur
opinion et on n'accepte pas que les gens
viennent
endommager notre économie et faire mal
et brimer la liberté
de leurs concitoyens par des
manifestations illégales
en extra chien
ayew merci une équation aux femmes la
prochaine question est de tonnes de
maître catalan toaster plus tôt réd elle
vous la parole
qui sont ces trucs
j'ai pas entendu réponse à la question
sur les renforts du agir si elle doit
justifier vous offrir plus de pouvoirs
aux policiers d'ottawa kambou tous deux
résidents et d'expériences police est en
activité policière il dit que c'était un
problème de leadership au lycée pas le
manque de pouvoirs qui sont au fond
d'eux est compétent à la police d'ottawa
de penser écoutez nous aurons le temps
de tirer toutes les leçons nécessaires
quand ce sera fini pour l'instant le
blues assuré que la police locale puisse
jouir des
permissions juridique pour faire le
travail mais aussi les ressources
supplémentaires
nous avons offert non seulement les
effectifs
que ce soit la grc ou de la ppe
la police provinciale de l'ontario nous
avons offert des ressources de
coordination
et les experts en logistique pour
s'assurer que nous puissions mettre fin
à cette occupation d'ottawa
vous avez mentionné monsieur trudeau
dommages à la réputation du canada
dont que l'affaiblissement de notre
degré de fiabilité commercial
quel était le point de bascule pour vous
est ce que c'était que la maison blanche
a commencé
s'exprimer et de protester
réponse écoutez les échanges que j'ai
eus avec notre député de windsor qui a
parlé de l'impact de la perturbation
dès le début du blocage l'impact sur les
travailleurs les travailleuses de
l'autre dans la région de windsor et
toute la chaîne d'approvisionnement due
to do rosario qui a été affectée
l'impact direct qui a fait du tort
exactement aux personnes
auraient été représentés soit disant par
ces manifestants non canadiens qui
s'offre eux d'un alors liberté de se
déplacer de voir des êtres chers de
l'autre côté de la frontière et jusqu'à
leur gagne pain en ligne avec des
barrages illégaux pensez-y
on a été là pour soutenir les polices
locales et maintenant nous nous offrons
de nouveaux outils pour ce faire
maintenant quand il est question de
l'affaiblissement de notre réputation
commerciale dans mes échanges avec des
leaders du monde entier
quant à l'ukraine et cela il est
question que je les démocraties tous
menacés sont presque peur des pays qui
s'en sortent à bien pendant la pandémie
avec des taux de vaccinations vraiment
remarquable les bonnes mesures
sanitaires voisins en score du ressac
contre ces mesures
et une frustration populaire des gens
qu'un nomade la pandémie
maintenant les paliers médias sociaux
vers cette femme n'est le financement
illégal voire illicite de ses activités
concertée visant à déstabiliser le pays
qui a le taux de vaccination parmi les
plus élevée du g7
du canada autour d'une question de nos
jeux qui
comment dire une faille de keaven jeu en
fait les caennais sont unis dans ce prix
c'est généralisé mais ils réagir en
faisant du tort à notre économie mais
voyons donc qui ne peut comprendre
l'inacceptable donc nous voulons montrer
que le canada demeure un pays
régi par la loi mais qui est prêt à
protéger ses infrastructures prêt à
protéger ces emplois près assuré le
gagne pain de tout un chacun est prêt à
laisser les biens les services circuler
librement c'est vraiment notre premier
devoir
à dieu merci un ex-fonctionnaire femmes
la prochaine question est de boris prou
le devoir jusqu'au ayad à vous la parole
on vous doit le ministre qu'elles
peuvent aller vous que les capacités
provincial ne sont pas suffisantes pour
gérer ce flux très content de pouvoir
tourner cette question vers le ministre
l'a métier
un bercy boris pour la question
évidemment la question la réponse se
trouve à travers le canada mais et ça se
trouve aussi la réponse dans les mesures
qu'on va prendre donc évidemment on va
appuyer les services policière à travers
le pays avec les ressources dont ils ont
besoin mais je vous dirige vers les
mesures annoncées par la vice premier
ministre la ministre des finances
aujourd'hui
c'est la capacité de
empêcher l'utilisation de la propriété
privée les camions disons qu'ils s'y si
on regarde les drapeaux ici sur les
rouages internes à toi il ya des
drapeaux québec qui est le drapeau
d'arbres auteuil il ya plusieurs
camions enregistrer partout au canada
juste juste jeu je remercie monsieur
fort pour avoir pris des mesures allant
thériault mais ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui nous permet et ça va
permettre soit
important très soit ici à toi
au service financières à travers le
canada de nous aider à
faire
faire sortir à dégager l'élu pourquoi
parce que ça touche
entièrement le canada et c'est dans une
telle mesure une telle loi qu'on peut le
faire on peut pas le faire avec des
mesures provinciaux
oui a suivi monsieur ministre une
province n'en veulent pas de ces d'état
d'urgence r quelque choisir de s'exclure
de démesure de rap aujourd'hui non selon
la loi est la loi a été rédigée par les
conservateurs le monsieur moroni 1,88
nous avons devoir de consulter avec les
provinces qu'on a fait
évidemment on va continuer à travailler
avec les provinces ce qu'on a fait est
ce qu'on va continuer à faire mais fois
qu'une urgence à l'échelle nationale est
déclenché
les lois s'appliquent à travers le
canada
on va prendre une dernière question
téléphone
un dernier suivi évidemment c'est une
loi qui s'applique sur l'entièreté du
canada mais les outils qu'on offre les
actions qu'on va prendre ne seront pas
appliquées partout à travers le canada
ne seront appliqués que là où ils sont
réellement nécessaire en travaillant
avec les juridictions locales donc oui
même si théoriquement
l'impact parce que c'est une loi
fédérale sur les mesures d'urgence ça
s'applique partout au canada ce ne va
avoir un impact
concret que où il y en a réellement
besoin et ça évidemment c'est pas
partout au canada opératrice
yu merci
l'actionnaire femmes la dernière
question est de marie qui watch the
globe and mail klich doha aide à vous la
parole
bon je me trouve
si j'ai bien compris musée un métier
la loi s'applique partout au canada les
provinces ne peuvent pas
se retirer à l'application la loi mais
en même temps vous dites qu'elle sera
ciblée alors où comptez-vous ciblé cette
joie dans ce cas la réponse
je vis des répondants français et je
suis contente de te rend dingue la casse
est important que les gens comprennent
ce point aux cannois sur les mesures
d'urgence tel qu'il est rédigé telle
qu'elle est appliquée quantification de
l'urgence de nature nationale ce qui
touche donc plus qu'une seule province
et c'est le cas donc nécessairement
c'est le territoire en est ainsi du
canada car c'est une urgence nationale
et c'est une loi fédérale
par contre les dispositions que nous
avons retenue dans
les mesures nécessaires ne
s'appliqueront que là où on en a besoin
nous ont parlé d'une limitation
géographique dans l'espace donc nous
voulons nous assurer que le pont
ambassador d'hommes meurent tout à fait
libres à la circulation
ça c'est un endroit où les mesures
contenues dans la loi vont pouvoir être
appliquée
ni bleu petite communauté bien loin des
frontières ou des infrastructures qui ne
connaît aucune activité importante
illégal
n'y verront que du feu
cela va les laisser complètement
indifférent et ya juste cette rousse
ligne
de limitation ou besoins et donc là où
il ya un passage quant à l'importance la
clue la police locale n'a aucunement
besoin de ressources additionnelles
vous même les outils qui sont à leur
disposition
il ne s'en serviront tout simplement pas
c'est vrai que si la loi s'applique aux
pays dans son ensemble
s'est limitée dans le temps et dans
l'espace fondée sur le besoin
question
pouvez vous donc
préciser si elle s'appliquera nous
sommes par exemple ou ailleurs dans
l'ouest
et quels sont les résultats qui vont
indiquer que vous êtes prêt à retirer la
loi
écoutez c'est très facile comme critère
pouvons nous arrêter la perturbation à
la chaîne d'approvisonnement peut-on
revoir les quarts de nuit et repartir
dans les usines d'assemblage est ce que
les citoyens les citoyens d'ottawa
peuvent reprendre
or trottoirs y inclus comme on l'a vu à
peine quelques semaines
une prothèse quand une manifestation
très simple de
ces fermiers de pommes de terre de l'île
du prince édouard se sont retrouvés sur
la colline parlementaire voilà comment
le feu y peuvent fonctionner voilà
comment les manifestations doivent se
passer mais cette occupation illégale
doit cesser et c'est pourquoi nous avons
annoncé la décision d'aujourd'hui
pour campus il m fait maintenant quand
il est question de kout d'un mot sont
les enjeux c'est un défi pour obtenir
des remorqueuses a fait d'eux des
classiques ces semi remorques massive
houser par exemple on a fait appel un
partenariat généreux avec les américains
afin que l'on puisse obtenir des
remorqueuses nécessaire maintenant
avec les mesures mises en place
nous aurons la capacité
d'obliger bien sûr contre rémunération
les exploitants north marqueuse de faire
le travail
vertu des contrats qu'ils ont signés
avec différents paliers gouvernementaux
afin de dégager la voie publique à la
voilà un outil supplémentaire qui
maintenant disponible aux polices
locales et partout au canada au besoin
il en reviendra à eux aux autorités
locales d'en décider
merci
ce n'est jamais signifia quand un
gouvernement mais une application
maintenant en passant une loi qui n'a
jamais servi depuis 1988
une loi adoptée par le premier ministre
malone et qui remplaçait la loi des
mesures de guerre du canada qu'est ce
que ça fait